all right everyone the price of bitcoin
is going up and people are asking why
the hell is bitcoin's price going up
well it is a confluence of different
events all coming together first is
bitcoin obviously topped out at 69 000
last year crashed all the way down to 40
000 now it is hilarious to think about
bitcoin crashed into 40k we dreamed
about that years and years ago but
ultimately here we are and so ultimately
i think a lot of people were selling
bitcoin they were worried about interest
rate moves from the fed and they became
oversold there was way more sellers than
buyers but those sellers eventually got
exhausted then this morning as we
started to get a little bit of relief in
the bitcoin price then all of a sudden
here comes the inflation number and the
official cpi inflation the
year-over-year growth for december was
seven percent that's right seven percent
inflation in the united states according
to the official numbers that is the
highest it has been in 40 years since
the early 1980s and so ultimately
obviously there are a lot of investors
who say what the hell am i doing holding
cash i have to find an inflation hedge
asset and so
when you see these big inflation numbers
you would expect bitcoin to be a
beneficiary of them and that's exactly
what happened we had bitcoin up
significantly today and ultimately what
i think people are being reminded of is
the fact that bitcoin is an inflation
hedge if you do not believe or trust the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
of a fiat currency that is controlled by
a government or a central bank and
ultimately you can opt out you can go
and you can hold the finite supply asset
of bitcoin it is a decentralized digital
currency with a programmatic monetary
policy there is no variability to that
monetary policy it simply is software
code that executes you know what the
code is going to do in advance you can
audit it at any time and it uses a
blockchain a third public ledger in
order to actually give people the
confidence and the auditability and the
verifiability to use this on a global
scale without having to trust any bank
any government any central bank or any
financial institution that's the beauty
of bitcoin and so whether it's that
there was enough sellers that eventually
got exhausted and or the fact that
inflation number came in the highest
it's been in 40 years bitcoin's going up
and it's just another step as more and
more people around the world join the
100 plus million people who already
understand bitcoin and hold bitcoin i
think over the next few decades we're
going to watch this asset continue to
get globally adopted and get priced by
the market and there's no way in my mind
that something like this is worth only a
trillion dollar market cap and so where
it goes nobody knows but i like our
chances